- The last time you were here,
so we weren't able to hug.
- No I got so excited to touch you.
- I know, the embrace was nice.
So, and our lives were very
different, both of them,
God, a lot has happened.
- Yes!
We should go out for a drink after this.
- I don't know if that'd be good.
We can go out for a drink right now.
Justin, here we go.
Yeah!
- Oh my gosh!
- We're gonna go for a drink right now.
Here's the thing,
- Thank you.
- It's been a rough go man.
- Thank you!
- It's been a rough go.
- This is the best thing.
I didn't expect this.
- I just wanted to say, I feel you girl.
- Cheers to us.
- I'm just saying it's been
a, it's been a rough go.
- This just became the
most fun talk show ever.
- But then also you, you were
on the cover of "Glamour."
- Yes!
- This is amazing.
Look at this.
- Yeah, thank you.
(audience cheers)
Me and my two friends.
- You are like, first of all.
Yes ma'am you work hard for that.
I'd show all that too.
No, you look so beautiful.
- Thank you.
- But you know what it
is, you look beautiful
but you look really strong.
- Thank you.
- I love that.
- I love that "Glamour" does represent
a lot of like strong women
and just amazing stories.
And I was so proud to be on the cover.
And I like it too.
It feels very fierce.
- Yeah. I know.
That was the word.
What did, so in the article
you got pretty personal
and very vulnerable.
That can be hard in this industry.
- I think for so many years
I have been, I'm very open.
- Me too.
- Yes you are.
And that's what I love about you.
And I'm very happy and life
is normally pretty good.
And I don't like complaining
because I have so much to be grateful for.
And this year I wanted to be very upfront
that it wasn't my best year.
- Yeah.
- And I've been very sad. (laughs)
- I think social media is so wonderful
for so many reasons.
But it shows just all the good stuff.
- All the filtered version of your life.
- It does, and it makes
you feel kind of crappy
when you look at someone else's life,
and you think they have it all.
- Yeah.
- And I just wanted to
tell everyone this time
that not everything is what it seems.
And I struggle like everybody else
because I do feel like I put
on a really pretty picture.
And I just wanted to be
honest, without whining.
There's like a fine line right?
- Yes but there's not...
Yes, but I think that we
are similar in the sense
that people always assume,
like you're very bubbly.
you're very nice, you're very welcoming.
You know what I'm saying?
Like when we go, people are generally,
but sometimes our lives aren't great.
- Yes.
- And sometimes you're sad.
- And sometimes you don't...
You know, it's like everybody
expects the comedian
you know you have to make
people laugh all the time.
That kind of thing.
I feel like if you're bubbly
and like that's our general
personality and we're talkative.
Like people expect that, and if you're not
then there's something really wrong.
And it's like, I'm just having...
- It's just a normal person.
- Yes, just a normal person
experiencing emotions.
- Having a lot going on.
It's funny too, when I
did open up a little bit
over the past year, even
with my close friends
who didn't know much that was going on,
I kept, I keep a lot of stuff close.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
And so they, I found to be so,
people really wanted to be there for me.
Like I didn't realize it.
Like I felt like it was such a burden
And I was trying to take
on everything by myself
until I realized I actually physically
couldn't do it anymore.
I was actually getting,
making myself sick.
- Yeah.
- And I finally like said it out loud,
like "I need help."
And saying those words almost killed me.
And then everyone was
like, "We wanna help you!"
Like all my friends
came out of the woodwork
and people at work.
- Yeah.
- And I like released
myself from this prison.
I feel like it was my
own self prison in a way.
- It's a very vulnerable
place to be there.
- There've been a lot of tears.
- I'm loving this too. (Laughs)
- Okay. Hold on.
(audience applauds)
- So you said something else,
I literally read this article
and I was like, "Oh my
God, you're in my head."
- Really?
- Because you said you'll
never get married again.
I will never get married again.
Not because I don't believe in love.
- I know! Same! I believe in love!
- Love is beautiful and it's not that.
I just did mot, that did not suit me.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, in my life.
And so I thought it was awesome
that you addressed that.
Not many people address it,
'cause I feel like where I'm from
you have to like, there's steps
and you have to, and it's just exhausting.
Cause it doesn't work in
everyone's life like that.
- Not in this and not the way we work.
I feel like we're just a
different type of person.
I want a relationship.
- Me too!
- Can't wait to have a
partner that I adore.
And I hope that's there for me.
But as far as, I don't
know the marriage thing,
Apparently I'm not great at
you know, and I'm
accepting my shortcomings.
- It's a hard thing to do.
- Yes.
- Especially 'cause a
lot of us get together.
Like I don't know about y'all,
but like from where I'm from, once again,
and I am like, I was old
at 30 to even meet someone
and then get married at 31.
That was like old.
I was almost dead where I'm from.
Like you know girls are gonna
get married at 20, you know?
- That is scary.
- I think, but once you
develop those patterns
in your life and it's worked,
it's hard to include another person.
I'm like 40 years old.
- It's hard.
- It's like hard like to do that.
So anyway, I thought it was awesome.
- And we love our jobs so much too.
- I love my job.
- I talked a lot about
that in the article too.
Like I'm trying to find some balance now,
which I feel like I never did,
it was like one track mind, work, career.
I know I'm learning to find
the, I think I said it.
I'm learning to find the gray.
I'm very black and white.
My personality is black and white.
How I go about things and I'm
trying to find some balance
'cause I've never had that before.
- I don't know if we
should be real good friends
'cause I don't think we'd
be good for each other.
- 'Cause we are exactly the same.
Am I speaking your language right now?
- That is so hard for me.
- It is hard.
- No it's either in or
out, or it's this or that.
And it's very hard for me
'cause then I feel like
I'm just being apathetic
in the middle.
- Me too.
And I don't like the middle road.
- Me either.
- I'm like one or the other.
But I have to I have to balance it now.
- It's healthy. It's healthy.
No I did too.
I started saying, "No," a lot.
So one of your friends and costars
on "The Flight Attendant,"
I love "The Flight Attendant,"
- Thank you!
- I'm so excited about the second season.
- So excited.
So she really helped you
through everything right?
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Zosia, yes, thank you.
(audience cheers)
Zosia is my co-star and my best friend.
And she helped me so
much through season two.
She basically lived with me the
last few months of shooting.
We just moved in together and she,
I don't think I would've
gotten to work some days
without her.
- Oh I have those friends.
Yeah, I have, yeah.
- Yeah.
And I didn't, I never thought
I had to depend on anyone
like that before.
And I like really depended
on her and she helped me
through so much and
she would have days off
and she would like, oh, I'm gonna cry.
She would like come to work on days
she didn't have to be there.
And like come and have lunch with me.
And I'm like, "You had
your day off today,"
and she's like, "I'm coming in"
'cause she heard I was like
having like a rough time
and she would like sit in my trailer
and she's there, she's the best.
I'm very lucky that I had her.
- Female friendships,
as far as I'm concerned,
are my most healthy relationships.
I feel like, other than my family,
and they're so good for us
because I feel like we connect.
Like even when I was married,
I mean you connect in a different way
than you do with your girlfriends.
- Totally different way.
It's totally different.
There's nothing like it.
- It's so good for us.
- I'm always promoting that
with my other, everyone.
I'm like, "You need to have
good girlfriends in your life."
It's so, so, so important.
- You know what? I don't
even know if I trust a girl
that doesn't have a girlfriend.
- That's a little strange.
You gotta have a good girlfriend.
That says a lot about you.
- I know, someone once
told me, they're like,
" I don't really have girlfriends."
And I was like, "That's not shocking."
(audience laughs)
I was like, "It's not shocking news."
- It's very clear.
- And we call each other out,
but we lift each other up.
It's like a really healthy, uh anyway.
- I totally agree.
- Season two of the show
"The Flight Attendant"
is on HBO Max.
And joining us now is
Kaley's friend and costar
in the series.
Everybody please welcome Zosia Mamet!
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
You look so cute.
All your little tattoos.
- Oh yeah.
- I didn't even see you with this outfit.
- I came to say hi but
you were already out here.
- Oh my gosh.
- You also both just
made me cry backstage.
So that was unfair.
- And your toes, they're
different on each.
- Oh that was...
- But that was my idea.
- That was her idea.
Also love my hands too.
- [Kelly] Oh, and the very tips!
- She likes to credit for her work.
- I can tell she's humble.
Well Kaley and I were just talking
about the strength of
having female friendships.
Have you always found that's
like really good for you
and healthy for you as well?
- Kaley will cry.
- I went...
- We both we're gonna cry.
Okay, don't ruin our makeup Kaley Cuoco.
- It looks so good.
I know. Leave it to me.
- Yes. I mean, I think, you know,
everyone has difficulties in their lives
and like I'm not super
close with my family
and I've always found chosen family
to be so exceptionally important.
And I think as women, like,
it's tantamount to anything.
Obviously like
relationships are important,
romantic relationships,
but I think female friendship
it brings it to another level.
(laughs) You're gonna make me cry.
- Is that a tattoo as well on your palm?
- It is a tattoo.
- She's a wild child.
If she could she'd tattoo her hair.
- Are these like, you drink
a lot and you're like,
"This would be awesome. Get a heart."
Or is this just like
you're... what is that?
- You don't even have to get
me drunk is the sad part.
Literally, if you right now were like,
"Do you wanna ditch this
and go get a tattoo?"
I'd be like, "Sure, let's go.
- No, because I'm
addicted to them as well.
I have like 20.
- Oh yeah.
- Like I have so many, but
they're all little small ones
- Me too.
Yeah, so that's why I was wondering
'cause a couple of mine were like,
"That sounds like our great idea!"
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm really happy that I haven't made any
like horrendous decisions.
- Me too.
Way to go, nicely done.
- Way to go.
- Yeah, with a lot of tattoos. It's nice.
- My husband drunkenly almost got
a pigeon tattooed on himself.
And I was like...
- The rats of the sky.
- Yeah, there you go.
I don't think I ever told you that.
- The rats of the sky. (laughs)
- Right on your body, that's amazing.
That's cool.
That's awesome.
So the show is now in season two,
is there like a multiple
personality thing going on?
Is that what's happening?
- One would think.
I play five Cassies this season.
- Is that fun?
That seems fun. It's not boring at all.
- [Kaley] It's not boring,
but it's a lot of working with me.
So I'd like to maybe...
- [Kelly] I know, that's
a narcissist run wild.
- Yes it is!
- This is what Kaley,
Kaley comes comes home from a day
of her working with
herself and she's like...
(Kaley snort laughs)
- I'm like, "You would not
believe how I acted today."
- I work with the biggest diva you know.
- I'm like, "You wouldn't believe
what went on with me today."
- But that had to be a little fun though
'cause you're not playing
the same character.
It's not monotonous.
- It was incredible.
It was also unbelievably hard work.
It was very technical.
Our team actually worked with
the team behind "Orphan Black"
if you guys know that show.
They did the same thing that we did.
It just was very technical.
A few days I would actually
play five different Cassies.
So I was like running back and changing.
And then I was like,
"What personality am I??
And it was great as an actor.
- That's what I mean!
- I got to flex a million muscles,
but yeah, it was a lot and it looks,
it was so hard to do,
but then watching it back
I see that it was totally worth it.
We definitely went big.
- It looks insane.
Also just to like brag
about her for a second.
- Don't brag about me.
- I'm going to brag about you.
- No, no, no, don't do it.
- I know because I was either there
or she would come home
and crying about it,
yeah and cry about it,
how insanely hard it was,
not only from a technical standpoint,
but from an acting standpoint,
what she was going through personally,
just the whole, this
shoot like was definitely
blood, sweat and tears for all of us.
And the first time I saw
one of the motion capture scenes,
which is her in gold dress Cassie
there was, and I was sitting
next to her on her couch
watching a producer's cut.
And I was like, "Is that
a different actress?"
Like she is so mind blowing,
playing these different parts.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- It's like she actually am,
she is a different human being
and it is five of her
and it is next level.
- [Kelly] I'm like, so excited.